- [Instructor] So as
some of you already know,
I really enjoy eating a good avocado,
which, despite its appearance
that it looks like a vegetable,
but it's actually a fruit.
And let's say that I eat
two avocados per day,
and I eat two avocados
per day for six days.
Now, there's a couple of
ways that I could think
about how many avocados did I eat?
I could say, hey, I eat two a day,
and I'm going to do that for six days,
so I'm gonna add six twos together.
So it'll be two, plus two,
plus two, plus two, plus two,
plus two, I have six
twos right over there.
And then I can add them together.
And we could say two plus two is four.
You add another two, you get to six.
You add another two, you get to eight.
Yet another two to get to 10.
Yet another two, you get to 12.
And that all is fine,
but there's an easier way
to express this repeated addition.
One way is to view it as multiplication.
Instead of just writing out six twos
and adding them together,
mathematicians have come up
with a neater way of writing that.
Let's say, okay, we're going
to add up a bunch of twos.
How many twos are we going to add up?
We're going to have six of those twos,
and we need to come up with
some type of a symbol for it.
So we will use this X-looking thing.
And so, six times two can be viewed
as repeated addition in
exactly this same way.
So six times two would be equal to 12.
And we could go the other way around.
If someone were to ask you,
what is four times three?
Pause this video and see
if you can write it out
as repeated addition, like we saw up here.
Well, one way to interpret this is to say,
this is four threes, so
we could say this is equal
to three, plus three,
plus three, plus three.
And three plus three is
six, six plus three is nine,
nine plus three is equal to 12.
You might be familiar with skip counting,
and you would say three, six, nine, 12.
Just out of curiosity,
what do you think three
times four is going to be?
Pause this video and try to represent it
as repeated addition, and then
see what you come up with.
Well, we can interpret
this as three fours.
And so, we could say this is going
to be four, plus four, plus four.
And if we skip count fours,
we'd have four, eight, 12,
(chuckles) I was about to
go to 16, four, eight, 12.
So this is going to be 12.
So this is interesting,
at least for this example,
for these two examples,
I got to the same thing.
Four times three got me the same result
as three times four, interesting.
I wonder if that's always true.
But anyway, big picture from this video is
that you can view multiplication
as repeated addition.